what's up everybody I'm Walter Binet
dziak and this is Tamara's never seen
today I'm watching big fish for the
first time so I've heard a lot about
this movie for a long time I've never
seen it because it's this Tim Burton
movie that a lot of people have
suggested to me and it doesn't seem like
a regular Tim Burton movie you know like
what I think Tim Burton I think of
Beetlejuice the first two Batman movies
Edward Scissorhands you know those kind
of films this is a much more er least it
seems like before watching it a much
more straightforward film than his more
outlandish crazy things like you know
the movies that I just mentioned in like
the animated stuff like corpse bride or
even Franken waiting so we're doing top
five best and worst Tim Burton movies
and I had to watch this one because a
lot of people think that this is either
one of his best or his best movie now
after seeing Ed Wood for the first time
I don't think that's gonna be possible
but it could change my mind so let's get
into big fish right now
[Music]
you
that was a tearjerker if there's one
word or phrase I could use to describe
that that one brought tears out of my
eyes a very effective father-son story
in the end but it's surrounded by all
these fantastical things happening so I
can see how Tim Burton added his own
flair to this because it's not just a
straightforward thing like I thought it
was gonna be it is very whimsical but
also has some supernatural elements to
it because the character that Albert
Finney plays who just passed away
unfortunately is this big storyteller
and he exaggerated exaggerate everything
that he you know tells a story about
every event in his life he makes bigger
and more grand and the stories that he
tells to other people and we get to see
a lot of those fantastical elements play
out on screen and they all have a kernel
of truth to truth to them which is you
know the point of the movie is that
there is sort of like this centre of all
these stories of these crazy things
happen but at the center there is a
little bit of truth that he's telling so
I could see how Tim Burton lended his
style to those kind of elements of the
movie and overall I definitely say it's
very enjoyable I will say through the
first maybe 30 percent of the movie I
was like I gotta convince me a little
bit more before I really got into it it
felt like a just a book I know it's
based on a book but it just felt like a
live-action book without any room for
artistic expression from the filmmaker
just felt like we're just doing the book
which can't work sometimes but this it
just felt like someone just were being
reading to me straight out of a book
which is like great because narration
can work really well sometimes but also
like the words and phrasing they were
using just felt like how someone would
describe something in a book and you
know a book is not a movie it's a visual
medium you need to show me what's
happening instead of explaining things
so this did well later on but first off
when I was you know watching it for
those first and on 20 minutes or
whatever I was a little like I don't
know but then it got really good and
what really got drew me into it was when
we saw Albert Finney's character as a
young man which is played by the
ever-charming Ewan McGregor ob1 he was
great the best smile of a man
I've ever seen the most charming guy
that I one of at least that I've seen on
screen I mean he's just so likable he's
also his not aged at all I just saw him
in Christopher Robin which came out over
the summer I think it looks exactly the
same as he did in this movie we'll come
on 2003 that was what 15 years ago now
ah that's crazy man this is also right
after after episode two came out for
Star Wars so he's still in kind of Star
Wars bores mode but he doesn't have know
the beard that he had an episode two or
the longer hair or anything like that
he's just Ewan McGregor he looks just
like this happy-go-lucky never-ending a
positive guy who has like a bottomless
pit of happiness but is what I can
describe him as in this movie Billy
Crudup plays Albert Finney's son in this
and he never really liked his dad or
just didn't he I mean that's they didn't
like him he just didn't understand him
so you know he always heard his dad tell
these crazy fantastical stories and he
wanted to know the truth his dad is is
likely dying in this film so he wants to
find out what is happening or what
happened in the past for real he wants
to know the real stories and his dad is
just not willing to tell him those real
stories because he as they say in the
movie he is those fantastical versions
of that story of any story that he tells
so he is like exaggerated he is larger
than life and he doesn't want to be
anything less than that to his son
so it's this interesting conflict of
what these the what the father wants to
be known as to his son and what the son
wants to find out about the father
so is this interesting conflict that we
see and it really tugs at your
heartstrings to skip to sort of the the
middle and the end of this with Billy
props character trying to get more of
the truth out of him and even going to
other people who would be more willing
to tell him about what you know these
stories how they actually played out in
real life than how his dad told him he
was kind of obsessed with knowing who
his dad really was and by the end like I
said he really is his stories and the
scene at the end
you haven't seen this which I would
absolutely recommend if you haven't
checked it out definitely watch that
movie without anyone spoiling it for you
the ending where the father is dying and
Billy Crudup scare achter is he's right
next to him he's the only person in the
hospital with him and he looks like he
has another heart attack or something
and he's slipping away and yet or he had
a stroke I think something that's some
kind of medical issue and he was about
to die in the hospital there's no one
else around Billy Crudup is about to
call the nurse but the dad does want him
to and he asked him like what happened
with the day he was born that's kind of
what all this was centered around what
really happened the day he was born
because he's a big fish and all that the
title the movie is tied into the
exaggerated version of this story that
the dad tells he's looking at him he
could barely talk he can't really he
kind of lost the movement in space
because of the stroke and he says that
you tell it you tell the story so Billy
Crudup right there makes up the story
that he thinks his dad would have told
and he's also a writer
Billy Krebbs character is a writer who I
think he's a fiction writer so he also
writes stories but he doesn't like tell
them aloud like his dad did so he comes
up with this story on the spot as his
dad is dying and just tears rolling down
his face and and just how he explained
what was happening just like lifting him
up on his bed he was light as a feather
and he didn't know why and he Brahmin to
like that lake or river area where the
big fish was and like all of his friends
it's the convergence of characters all
of his friends throughout his life and
family were there and he like lays him
in the water he turns into the big fish
and he just way it's very sad and then
we flash back to reality and you know
the colors are D saturated everything is
back to kind of what real life would mor
look like less fantastical less colorful
and he slips away kind of with I don't
know if is the smile on his face but you
could tell he was happy I think anybody
can relate to this just having having a
father or the lack of a father or
anything like that you know we all come
from some kind of family and to see that
played out especially with a father-son
dynamic anybody can put yourself in
those shoes
and get some kind of emotional residence
out of it and it was man it was tough to
watch in a good way just in a way that
drew emotion out of you and to really
try and appreciate what we have with our
fathers or what we did have with our
fathers or father figures it's important
to to be present in those moments
because we never know when those are
going to fade away so I hope if you guys
haven't seen this movie it means a lot
to you because you'll just see him for
the first time if I would have grown up
with it or if I saw it when I was a
little bit younger I definitely would
have a bigger emotional attachment to it
than I do now do I think it's better
than Ed Wood well check out the top five
and see if I think that I don't know
yeah this was a really really good movie
and it's something that I would suggest
for anyone to check out it's a great
family story especially about the
fathers and sons and and also just about
you know sort of exaggerated tales and
there's a lot of really fun elements in
it we get to see a really cool arc for
the dad character as we see him grow as
you and McGregor and the past scenes
grows from a younger man to a little bit
of an older man and he he goes back to
this town called Specter that's sort of
like an allegory for heaven at first and
it's like this hidden place but then we
find out it's a real place and he goes
back there and kind of buys up the town
and rebuilds it and that was kind of his
life's calling that we saw play out
second toe only to his son because we
see some other almost infidelity things
kind of come up and he didn't want to
betray his wife and son and family is
really at the core with sort of the
outer shell of that being Specter and
wanting to stay at this town that he
thought was amazing when he was younger
steeper so he's also and if there's a
lot of like like stars that you wouldn't
expect to see in there in there like I
think dandy media was in there as well
there was a really great love story that
we got to see play out with Ewan
McGregor in the flashbacks and play down
the mom on that
Jessica Lange from the younger days so
yeah man this is something I think you
should see and you know bring some
Kleenex or tissue paper with you
whatever cuz it might bring up a little
bit of Tears deservingly so so big fish
is fantastic do have to give a hair flip
rating okay if I were to give this
something I think I would give it we're
not doing point fives or anything like
that so it's gotta be a solid number
I would round it up to eight hair flips
so I don't have hair but you know long
enough hair so let's just oh my that was
intense I like that I know what she
likes that one too thank you for
watching this episode of timers never
seen make sure you tune in next week
what are you doing here
I'm watching big fish Tamers never seen
but I've seen big fish it's my favorite
movie of all time what did you like it
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you